Mika ouis serre un peu les reculements
devant s'il te plaît serr ici là mets
les deux trous qui restent il doit y
avoir une marque faut m à la marche ça
fait au 5e ouais et ça sera le bon
réglage pense ouais bon on va régler
Arnet bien attaché avant le grand départ
comme chaque année depuis 2018 Johann et
ses équipes se mettent en selle pour la
collecte des sapins de Noël des
habitants de maison la fite avec leur
entreprise les cèges de Versailles ils
réalisent l'opération à cheval en moins
d'une semaine au pied des domiciles 15 à
20 km sont parcourus chaque jour pour 5
he à travers les rues allez c'est
bien nous sommes trois paratlage donc
une personne qui mène les chevaux he
donc le cocher qui je te disais tout à
l'heure et bien il y a une rotation
puisque nous sommes tous cochés et donc
à la fois riper donc les gens qui
chargent les qui chargent les sapins et
quelqu'un un petit peu dans la ben aussi
parce que les sapins étant très
volumineux nous sommes obligés un petit
peu de les ranger et de les tasser pour
pouvoir en mettre un nombre conséquent
pour rentabiliser un petit peu les
tournées et justement pas devoir
allonger les temps de travail des
chevaux et tout ça
voilà une initiative originale et
écologique permettant d'éviter
l'utilisation d'un camion pour le
dernier jour de ramassage ce mardi 16
janvier de calèche et qu chevaux de
trait sont sollicités de Ras Percheron
et cob normand ces animaux sont
sélectionnés pour leur élégance et leur
endurance un atout sympathie attisant
l'enthousiasme de la population c'est un
signe marqueur pour tous les habitants
il il repèent les calèches cette année
on les a bien décorés donc on les voit
de loin on entend le bruit des sabots
euh les les voitures qui sont derrière
qui sont un peu bloquées finalement euh
ne rouspettent pas trop hein ça fait ça
fait partie du folklore au pays du
cheval c'est quand même la moindre des
chaes c'est trop chouette euh non c'est
une super belle belle action merci à la
ville de d'instaurer ça 2500 sapin
naturel auront été ramassés lors de ces
5 jours de collecte
hippomobile prochaine étape la
transformation des végétaux Royas
utilisé comme déserban pour la commune
nouveauté cette année les mansoniens
pourront aussi en récupérer gratuitement
pour leur jardin rendez-vous près du
Palais Omnisport pierre du prè jusqu'au
21 janvier prochain pour en
profiter